- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to try to compute
what tangent of 13 pi over 12
is without using a calculator.
But I will give you a few hints.
First of all, you can rewrite
tangent of 13 pi over 12
as tangent of,
instead of 13 pi over
12, we can express that
in terms of angles where we
might be able to figure out
the tangents just based
on other things we know
about the unit circle.
13 pi over 12 is the same
thing as 15 pi over 12
minus two pi over 12,
which is the same thing as the tangent
of five pi over four
minus pi over six,
or we could even view it as
plus negative pi over six.
So that's my hint right over there.
So pause this video and
see if you can keep going
with this train of reasoning
to evaluate what tangent
of 13 pi over 12 is
without using a calculator.
All right, now let's
keep on going together.
Well, we already know what the tangent
of the sum of two angles are.
We've proven that in another video.
We know that this is going to be equal
to the tangent of the
first of these angles,
five pi over four,
plus the tangent of the second angle,
tangent of negative pi over six,
all of that is going to be over
one minus tangent of the first angle,
five pi over four,
times the tangent of the second angle,
negative pi over six.
And so now we can break
out our unit circles
to figure out what these things are.
So I have pre-put some unit circles here.
And so let's first think about
what five pi over four looks like.
Pi over four,
you might already associate
it with 45 degrees.
That's pi over four right over there.
Two pi over four would get you here.
Three pi over fours would get you there.
Four pi over four, which
the same thing as pi,
gets us over there.
Five pi over four would
get us right about there.
Now, you might already recognize
the tangent of an angle
as the slope of the radius,
and so you might already be able to intuit
that the tangent here is going to be one,
but we can also break out
our knowledge of triangles
in the unit circle to figure this out
if you didn't realize that.
So what we need to do is
figure out the coordinates
of that point right over there,
and to help us do that,
we can set up a little
bit of a right triangle,
which you might immediately recognize
is a 45-45-90 triangle.
How do I know that?
Well five pi over four,
remember we go four pi
over four to get here,
then we have one more pi
over four to go down here.
So this angle right over
here is pi over four
or you could view it as 45 degrees.
And of course, if that's
45 degrees and that's 90,
then this has to be 45 degrees
'cause they all add up to 180 degrees.
And we know a triangle like
this by the Pythagorean theorem,
if our hypothesis is one,
each of the other two sides
is square root of two over
two times the hypotenuse.
So this is square root of two over two
and then this is square
root of two over two.
Now, if we think about the coordinates,
our X coordinate is square
root of two over two
in the negative direction.
So our X coordinate is negative
square root of two over two
and our Y coordinate
is square root of two over two going down,
so that's also negative
square root of two over two.
And the tangent is just
the Y coordinate over
the X coordinate here.
So the tangent is just going to be
negative square root of two over two
over negative square root of two over two,
which is once again, one,
which was our intuition.
So we can write the tangent
of five pi over four
is equal to one.
And then what about negative pi over six?
Well, negative pi over six,
you might recognize pi over
six as being a 30 degree angle.
Pi is 180 degrees, so
divided by six is 30 degrees,
and negative pi over six
would be going 30 degrees
below the positive x-axis.
So it would look just like that.
And as we said, this angle
right over here is pi over six,
which you can also view
as a 30 degree angle.
If we were to drop a
perpendicular right over here,
you might immediately recognize this
as a 30-60-90 triangle.
We know if the hypotenuse
is of length one,
the side opposite the 30 degree side
is 1/2 the hypotenuse,
and then the longer non-hypotenuse side
is going to be square root of
three times the shorter side,
so square root of three over two.
And so our coordinate's right over here,
we are moving square
root of three over two
in the positive X direction,
square root of three over two,
and then we're going negative
1/2 in the Y direction,
so we put negative 1/2 right over there.
And so now we know that the
tangent of negative pi over six
is going to be equal to negative 1/2
over square root of three over two,
which is the same thing
as negative 1/2 times,
let me write it this way, negative 1/2
times two over the square root of three,
which is equal to negative one
over the square root of three.
This right over here is one.
We saw that there.
And then this right over here
is negative one over the
square root of three.
And then this is negative one
over the square root of three.
And so I can rewrite this
entire expression as being equal
to one minus one over the square to three,
all of that over one,
and then I have a negative
here and a negative here,
so then that becomes, a
negative times a negative,
so positive one plus one over
the square root of three.
And if we multiply both the
numerator and the denominator
by square root of three,
what we're going to get in the numerator
is square root of three minus one
and then our denominator is going to be
square root of three plus one.
And we are done.
That's tangent of 13 pi over
12 without using a calculator.